all right my next guest huge star blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah
big-time blah blah movies television
he's done it all like bogie and Bacall
yeah ladies and gentlemen a good friend
and neighbor Adam Sandler Adam how you
doing what are you only good neighbors
everyone else on the block is so scared
of you I know what why are they scared
of me why do people in this neighborhood
afraid of me you do that you do that
weird freckled naked run every morning
at that foot like do it come and you
scream it on the cone man over and over
it's crazy I like to show people what I
got I like to get outside you get rid of
that you get rid of it right away every
morning like here it is here it is let's
move on next not speculate I'm gonna let
everyone see what I'm packing how's the
quarantine going for you Adam ah just
like everybody else Tony I'm here I'm
the kid like usually like the run away
to the hoe daddy's losing it again let's
go out let's go shopping
yeah now they're kind of now they're
really getting to know me and they're
really not one of them is happy being
here there's you know I've been yelling
more than I used to now you do you do
you are a bit of a Yeller I've been
around you when you yell yeah your your
guy likes to yell and say kids kids what
are we doing we gotta go we gotta go
that's you in normal circumstances what
are you doing now in quarantine well
usually it's been a known fact that I
scream all the time but it goes away
reasonably quick I have to say my
screaming has extended like this a new
version of me the kids are like okay
it'll go away and then they're like
looking at each other like oh he's still
going and I'm going I have just very
tense about everything and I'm just like
don't you touch that
that's it I didn't clean that yet and
mommy did you know I'm just I'm worried
about everything clean to the house and
you're wiping everything down I wipe a
lot of stuff down then when I pick it up
pick up things to eat I'm like oh yeah
did I already touch that are my hands
dirty so I clean my hands again and you
how about you buddy you doing anything
are you just kind of just sitting there
allowing everyone else to do it for you
in your home you still have a staff in
your home yeah I have a hundred and
seventy people here you can't do that at
this time really no one told me now I'm
told me a specific order by the governor
of California you can't have ten or more
in the house don't eat off let all those
guys I let half my people go and it's
now a hundred and seventy people they
dress me they wipe me down with alcohol
they thought they'd feed me soup they do
my they put my wig on everything is
taken care of they paint the freckles on
are you getting outside the house you do
ever go outside yes I had a terrible
situation happen now they're not
terrible but can I tell you going to use
it yeah you can tell me no one's gonna
see this that's all so I'm on I take the
kids out in the nude or we got a dog
basil begging expecting everyone else to
be keeping their distance right you can
go outside as long as you're far away
from other people
stay away man the six feet thing I'm
making about 30 feet like just let's
let's get away stay away from other
people children let's if we got it we
don't want to give it if they got it we
don't want to get it anyways I got the
dog and I noticed some people don't have
the dogs on the leash and I know I see
if dogs come into my dog and then I'm
gonna have to like separate with all
this is gonna be a fight the guys gonna
come over well I'm gonna have to be
close to this guy breaking up a fight so
I start screaming hey put the dog on a
leash put your daughter so then this
nice lady is walking towards us me too
wiping the kids and I say can you put
your dog on a leash she goes what
hey she does I said can you put your dog
on a leash because what's this and she
was on the on the phone or something
she's gonna hear me calm he starts
getting closer to me I go no no can you
put your dog on a leash she goes I live
right there I know I know I know just
the dog I don't want the dog she goes
you don't always have your dog leash I
know well I I know but that Corona thing
she just won and she starts coming at me
and I'm a crazy person she's getting
near my family said I started going
like a crater she goes you are a jerk
and she starts screaming at me that I
was a very very corona tense moment for
us and I yeah but you know let me tell
people something that woman's name was
Barbara Streisand I didn't mean to be
abrasive or loud I meant to just say get
the dog on a leash you shouldn't be
having dogs touch each other and getting
close to each other that's it yeah
all right I'm tall and I think you were
being reasonable in that situation I
think we're all a little tense and I
think you handled yourself well and I
hope barbara streisand gets it together
she just by the way I woke up this
morning with his long message people
people who need and I was like ah she
sided they got with it see it turns out
nice